this is a video about a mechanic I love
a commander card I hate and a bizarre
deck I built out of spite our tale
begins in 1998 with urza Saga bringing
all sorts of horrendous to the
world and also a gift the cycling
mechanic it's a beautifully simple
mechanic you can pay an alternate cost
on a card and discard it in order to
draw a card this began in simple fashion
during öa block but 5 years later onslot
block added a ton of Dimension to the
mechanic varied cycle costs triggers
atted to cycle abilities cycling for
Basic Land types and six cards with
triggered abilities when other cards
were cycled these six were varying power
levels with one in particular being just
excellent but we'll talk about that a
bit later cycling has seen additional
prints every few years since and for a
simple reason people like this mechanic
as an alternate cost ability it adds a
lot of flexibility to cards which leads
to interesting decision- making every
cycling card a player draws prompts the
question is this card better than a
different card plus a small Mana
commitment this is nice in aggro when
running out of gas might be a concern
and it's even more useful in a control
deck where that Mana cost can be spent
on the end of an opponent's turn or even
in response to things to dig for answers
on top of this since cycled cards are
discarded and go to the graveyard they
work well with graveyard synergies
providing a near effortless way to put
cards in the yard and that's only the
play Styles helped out by the mechanic
innately remember that cool Onslaught
card I mentioned earlier Astros slide
has seen a ton of experimentation ever
since it was printed as it synergizes
with many different cards and offers a
ton of flexibility as a result it was
kind of understood as the core of any
cycling deck before 2020 astral slide
decks have a super interesting play
style that revolves heavily around
strategic resource management and in a
way that feels very in line with the
fundamental nature of the mechanic
number of cycling cards in hand
constantly dictates the Strategic
direction of the deck when you have more
you can get Bolder and set up for more
daring turns as well as using slide
triggers more liberally as blocker
elimination to net small value off etbs
and so forth or casting a card
normally by contrast when you have fewer
cycling cards in hand each one is pure
gold you always want to save them for
protecting a critical creature or
disrupting a dangerous play from an
opponent but if you feel the game
slipping away you can also choose to
gamble that lifeline on an endstep for a
little bit of value in addition Mana is
a super important resource for both
astral slide and the mechanic as a whole
as land counts dictate how safe you feel
playing setup pieces and how bursty your
turns can be a more controlling cycling
deck constantly forces a player to think
probabilistically if I spend Mana to
play a spell on my turn what are the
odds I'll be able to handle a key threat
on my opponent's turn if it gets played
what are my odds of drawing an
additional cycling card or an answer off
the top how much Mana would I need to
have the best chance of averting death
in a worst case scenario these questions
are also fundamentally tied to deck
construction since a player must always
weigh the strength of a cycling card
versus the the cycling cost of it as a
card a chroma's vengeance is wildly more
powerful than winged Shephard but if I'm
sitting there on an opponent's turn with
four Mana open looking down the barrel
of defeat I know which of the two I'd
rather have in hand in short the cycling
mechanic creates and promotes far more
textured and strategic gameplay than the
vast majority of mechanics in magic
gathering with all of that deep
strategic texture in mind let's talk
about Gabby Nest warten it's a five Mana
25 who makes the first cycle each turn
free and who creates a cat when you draw
your second card each turn this card is
strong enough to be a natural choice for
a cycling commander and also deathly
boring free Cycles on each turn roves an
entire dimension of the cycling mechanic
and on top of that it highly encourages
a stable quantity of cycling one per
turn maybe two on an opponent's turn
sometimes every cycle past that is a
waste since you have to pay for it and
you don't even get a cute little Dino
cat and every turn you fail to cycle is
also a waste come on it's free real
estate this ability and the associated
incentives remove the status of cycling
cards as an important resource to be
saved and used carefully and also in
turn leave players with a lot of extra
Mana that they didn't have to plan out
what does that Mana get spent on well
permanent is the generate value when
cards get cycled of course Gaby destroys
most of the cool strategic
decision-making generally involved with
playing a cycling deck and replaces it
with yet another do the thing value pile
mid-range deck the design to Gabby deck
is such that if you do the thing cycling
in this case you get an effortless
mixture of card advantage and board
Advantage spread out over time just like
the other 80% of EDH Decks that exist
out there and this isn't because Gabby
players are people who like especially
boring decks the card is precision
designed to encourage exactly this type
of gameplay even if you build it from
scratch rather than buying a
precon it's a Betrayal on the part of
Wizards of the Coast of everything cool
about the cycling mechanic and it
creates totally predictable gameplay
well except for one thing you see the
other thing Gaby incentivizes is cards
with high cycling costs this is maybe
the one thing about the card that's not
dead boring but not really in a good way
okay so this incentivization is most
relevant for one specific cycle of cards
from Scourge and since Gaby doesn't pay
the bonus cost of decree of Justice it's
actually mainly relevant for two cards
the first is decree of Silence
big whoop it's a free counter spell
you'll have sometimes not much to say
here the other is decree of
annihilation I'll here deliver a hot
take nuking lands is may be okay may be
pretty cool if your play group is down
for that and also if you actually have a
way of ending the game pretty soon after
using that wild swing of momentum but
nothing else about Gaby really promotes
that sort of deck style more likely
you'll keep slowly getting cats
everybody's Mana base will gradually
recover and congratulations you've just
doubled the length of this game Gabby
into decree of annihilation while
certainly unusual still kind of fails to
be
interesting so we have here this pretty
bland commander and if you ask an EDH
player what they think about cycling
she's what they think of this cool
mechanic with a rich history and tons of
synergy potential reduced down to yet
another value pile Commander now to any
Gabby players out there I want to say
this is not an attack on you and Gaby is
more interesting than a lot of
commanders out there there are still
some interesting synergies and fun
instant speed plays to be had piloting a
gabby deck I don't hate it because it's
a uniquely bad design it's not I hate it
because it's a total betrayal of one of
my favorite mechanics and this isn't
just about Gabby either Wizards has a
habit of printing what I'll call
designer commanders which I hear use to
mean commanders that take a particular
mechanic and fully dedicate themselves
to it dictating a very specific and
often very boring type of deck based
around that
mechanic another example is elth
Crossroads augur taking scry a neat top
of Library manipulation mechanic and
literally just replacing it with value
in a way that doesn't synergize with
anything related to the original
Mechanic cool these commanders push
players toward less interesting decks
and their specificity causes them to
offer a narrow range of possible decks
to be built a popular typographic format
for this sort of Commander is one with
two lines of text one that says whenever
X happens y happens and another that
says whenever enough y's happen a z
happens this is a template that builds
its own deck you run some cards that do
X and Y and maybe some Z payoff if
you're feeling nutty some people might
enjoy this type of deck and to those
people I have to say that's great there
are certainly people out there who want
these kinds of cards newer players
people who don't want to spend too long
on deck building or people who like to
make unexpected versions of seemingly
straightforward commanders and I think
it's cool that wizard of the coast has
given them lots of options to work with
but if you want to try out an
alternative form of commander deck
building I'm here to offer you a vision
of what that could be for the rest of
the video I'm going to talk about how I
took one look at Gaby and then turned
around and built a truly bizarre cycling
deck it started with me absent-mindedly
cruising through random Onslaught cards
looking for deck ideas as one does and
as expected I saw astral slide but also
another enchantment wasn't familiar with
overbooked Cemetery these seem kind of
neat together right one promotes cycling
the other works well after I cycle
creatures into the graveyard with these
in my pocket I decided to include blue
as well since it's a very useful color
for both cycling and instant speech
Shenanigans and I started shopping
around for a commander in esper colors
My Hope was to find a commander that
could be a flexible value engine when I
flickered cards with astral slide and
this was my short list eventually I
decided all of them were were either too
generic too Niche or not the right Vibe
all except good old
shirom with my commander selected I set
some healthy ground rules no sculpting
Steel type Combos and a $100 budget I'm
not building a high power shirom deck
I'm building an astral slide deck a good
place to start is always windc cons and
one that left out immediately was
Magister Sphinx which combined with
shirom can One-Shot a player Sherm's
nature as a reanimation tool means that
a beatdown swe with a number of big
flying artifact creatures is likely to
be a good bet at $100 cycling deck power
levels and will hopefully offer enough
beef to win even when Magister Sphinx
isn't
available however this Beatdown step
will likely be tricky unless I'm mostly
stabilized against hate and attacks
which can be accomplished through my
core card of Astral
Slide the card offers so many use cases
it's a reanimation Engine with shum it
can be a value removal ramp or life gain
Engine with other artifact creatures and
that's to say nothing of the built-in
protection and disruption utility of the
card since Astros slide is so key to the
deck and I can only run two in the deck
enchantment tutors were a must so I
started out with idilic tutor and
eventually settled on Zur as my other
tutor his wizard tag is oddly important
as Wizards of the Coast has printed two
wizard cycling cards basically instant
speed wizard tutors that count as a
cycle out of these strange cards
organically grew a toolbox that expanded
as I found new hurdles my deck needed to
overcome wizard cycling grabs a tutor
for slide a tutor for my top end boys a
recursion spell for my slides and a
stifle effect that's also an extra cycle
for my big turns a mixture of tutoring
discard outlets and my recursion spell
Commander means that my deck's key
pieces generally get into play Mana
efficiently the deck does a great job
scratching my itch to play a complex and
strategic deck and it does so at a
middling power level that feels good in
quite a lot of
pools a key takeaway from this deck
building process for me was the strength
of flexible groundup deck construction
by starting with a mechanic and a couple
key cards and selecting a commander
afterward my deck ended up with a
foundation that includes the commander
but doesn't wholly consist of the
commander it's built to follow best
practices for a cycling deck and though
it does include the occasional stormy
element or value engine each of these
pieces are intentional and most of them
are T durable if I decide that's what a
given situation demands the most
important thing I prefer to avoid is
having the entire deck stand on the
shoulders of the commander at least not
unless you're ready for that kind of
responsibility I could have made the
commander Zur but then the issue of not
having a consistent value Source
combined with Zur being a removal magnet
would have rapidly turned my deck into
one more Zur than astral slide as draw
enchantments and protection spells
gobble up my deck space it's good to
keep in mind the sort of deck building
incentives a given Commander pushes onto
you as even one that seems like a good
idea on paper might make your deck take
a turn that isn't what you were looking
for if I was to w WRA this up with a bow
I'd go with this when you're building a
deck figure out what the deck wants to
do and try to turn that into a somewhat
focused plan except that you won't nail
the first version of the deck and that
there's room to adapt as you encounter
further problems I'd say there are four
key versions of a single deck the first
principles version in your brain the
draft version after you actually hammer
out a 100 card list the Streamline
version completed after you solo play
test a bit and the final version
completed after you played against other
people for a little while each of these
steps will solve a different set of
problems that the deck has and that's a
strength